Joe Biden has won the American
presidential election this is a fraud
on the American public in a stunning
display from a sitting president Donald
Trump launching an assault on the
Integrity of the election losing is
never easy not for me it's not
the aftermath of the 2020 presidential
election sent shockwaves through the
foundations of American democracy
right now they're watching us to see if
we have a democracy
I know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the Capitol building
across the country allegations of fraud
meant election officials found
themselves under attack there were some
death threats people like me will really
me go after people like you he said that
they were coming to take me out to kill
me you're gonna pay for it you will pay
for it we're in an environment right now
where election officials are being
targeted baseless claims a widespread
voter fraud and unwarranted abuse of
election officials raised the level of
discontent with the democratic system to
a boiling point have trial by combat
and today 40 of Americans don't believe
that Joe Biden is the legitimate
president United States that's a scary
place to be
as the risk of political violence
increases will the results of the
upcoming midterms make the 2024
presidential elections the ultimate
Challenge to American democracy
[Music]
on September 1st 2022 Joe Biden warned
voters that the nation was under threat
equality and democracy are under assault
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic it can
be compared to the kind of approach that
Donald Trump has taken although that's a
stretch but he still basically saying a
large chunk of of the American
population is now a threat to the
survival of American democracy and
that's a pretty strong statement for
president United States to make
democracy cannot survive
when one side believes there are only
two outcomes to an election either they
win
or they were cheated some Republicans
actually approved of Biden's speech I
agreed with just about everything he
said I think that it's important to talk
right now about the anti-democratic
forces that are at work in American
politics specifically that are generated
by Trump 67 percent of all Americans
worry the nation's democracy is in
danger of collapse and 71 percent of
those who voted for Trump in 2020
believe America will be less of a
democracy within a generation
Americans are really concerned if you're
a Republican or Democrat you see the um
the threat in the kind of mirror
opposite terms Republicans have bought
the by and large Donald Trump's claim
that the 2020 election was stolen and as
a result they think that the system is
now rigged the overriding concern on the
Democratic side now is that the
Republicans suspicion that the system is
being rigged leading to not just threats
of political violence but actual
political violence at a moment there's a
war being waged against the Integrity of
the American electoral system from false
claims of widespread voter fraud to
questioning the validity of Voters poll
workers and ballots Trump and his allies
have been seeding doubt there's a few
other people I'd like to send right down
to the prison down here in Florence
anybody who was involved in that corrupt
Shady shoddy election of 2020.
this was the scam of the century and
this was the crime of the century
but attacks on the Integrity of
Elections have gone beyond casting doubt
on votes we found at the start of 2021
that state lawmakers were introducing an
unprecedented number of restrictive
voting laws these are laws that make it
harder for eligible Americans to
register to vote and stay on the voter
rolls
in 2021 state legislators proposed more
than 566 voting restriction bills 93
percent of them put forward by
Republicans
the majority of them failed or were
rejected but of the 52 enacted across 25
States
45 were proposed by Republicans some of
whom supported Trump's lie election
denialism and voter fraud has been used
to justify many of these restrictive
laws that have been passed in the last
two years
voters can start to doubt the Integrity
of the whole system even if they don't
believe the lies and so voting which is
an activity that should be
straightforward simple to accomplish and
part of what we get to do as part of a
democracy then becomes saddled with
barriers the restrictions differ from
state to state but they include
narrowing who is allowed to cast mail-in
ballots limits on the use of dropboxes
restricting the window of time voters
have to request and submit their ballots
and voter ID restrictions
foreign we are seeing efforts in
republican-controlled States
to make it harder to vote there's no
simpler way to put it now there already
is a patchwork of rules in place across
the country in some states like New York
which is dominated by democrats they
actually can be pretty hard to vote in
New York but their efforts underway to
make it easier what we're seeing in some
republican-controlled states Georgia
Texas are two examples or efforts to
make it harder what we see with these
kinds of restrictions is that it puts
communities of color over and over again
at a real disadvantage
and so Core Democratic voters can wind
up being effectively disenfranchised
this way
Six States have gone a step further
right now Alabama Arizona Florida
Georgia Kentucky and Oklahoma have
passed nine election interference laws
in 2022. for example some of these laws
criminalize election officials from
encouraging a person who may be eligible
to vote by mail to indeed apply to vote
by mail
so think about if you're a voter with a
disability or you're an elderly voter or
you're somehow otherwise qualified to
vote by mail that kind of behavior of
just encouragement to use a perfectly
legal form of voting is now criminalized
and that election official is now
subject to prosecution hi I'm John Prado
The Economist U.S editor our journalists
roam America every week looking for the
most interesting most important stories
about U.S politics if you want to see
all our coverage of U.S politics the
midterms what they mean for America our
election forecast model then please
click on this link
despite previous voting restriction laws
there's been an upward Trend in voter
turnout during elections however the
impact of the latest round of
restrictions on the 2022 midterms is yet
to be determined
but the fear of prosecution isn't the
only thing concerning election workers
frotted out America of a re-election
where Donald Trump blew European lioness
out of the water and guess what you
should be executed under Federal Prison
the 2020 presidential election cycle was
the most stressful and challenging of my
career I would have never thought
that I would have to go through
something like that it was awful it will
kill you we will demand an audit he will
demand the truth liberal ass lie and
Rhino we will take you out they used a
lot of sexual terms and that I deserved
a knife to my throat deserved to be
executed publicly it was until we got to
the first stop sign
that we realized that we were being
followed it was
awful awful night Trump further fueled
the abuse by publicly calling out
several election officials who helped
certify the results for me it got worse
when Trump put me up on a big screen at
a rally here in Valdosta Georgia I'm
going to ask you to look up at that very
very powerful and very expensive screen
I do this for a few people let's go that
is disheveled Fulton County elections
Chief Richard Baron hope you're happy
because you know whose fault this is
when it's the goddamn fan because you
know it's coming I received at least 150
voicemails there were some death threats
I ended up resigning
it went to a whole different level after
the president mentioned me by name and
suggested that I was trying to cover up
some sort of widespread election fraud
in Philadelphia that was costing him the
election the threat certainly became
much more specific and largely targeted
my children
one of the extraordinary and
extraordinarily upsetting spectacles
that we all witnessed during this last
election cycle was we had a president
United States directly reaching out to
state election officials and and
pressuring them intimidating them to
take some action to change the vote
count I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have he
invited senior lawmakers from Michigan
to come to the White House to press his
case with them directly
I never seen something like that happen
before and in each of those cases the
state officials had the guts to hold the
line
[Music]
but in several States election officials
who refused to bow to the pressure from
Trump's allies have been censured or
replaced
one of the things that has become very
clear on the Republican side is that if
you don't fall in line if you speak out
against the big lie you are cast out of
the parties
you are seen now as a traitor for
telling the truth there are still
Republicans like me out there but a lot
of them are leaving the Republican party
because it really has moved to a more
radical place
[Applause]
the election hysteria of 2020 has
brought the mechanics of Elections to
the fore and exposed vulnerabilities
all elections are operated by each
individual state election administrators
clerks registrars and Recorders are
responsible for running the elections
and have the vital role of counting the
votes the final word on certifying and
Reporting the result is given to the
chief election official
the trend for who Wants these jobs has
been changing
there's been a concerted effort by
Donald Trump and his loyalists
specifically Steve Bannon to try to
recruit people at these incredibly local
levels of government the people who
would certify the people who would count
for taking over school boards we're
taking over the Republican party for the
precinct committee strategy we're taking
over all the elections suck on this and
we're going to decertify the electors
okay and you're gonna have a
constitutional crisis but you know what
we're a big and tough country and we can
handle that
alongside this push for election deniers
to join at the local level a lot of work
is happening higher up the process
my biggest concern right now is people
running for office who've now won
primaries or in general elections for
key positions like governor and
Secretary of State key to determining
the outcome of a vote who say they
believe that the last election that was
stolen and are saying well they wouldn't
let something like that happen again in
other words they're effectively running
on a promise to interfere in elections
to achieve the outcome that their party
wants and that's that's a frightening
and new development
28 trump-backed candidates are in the
running for high-ranking state-level
positions those that are responsible for
election certification when arizonans
had concerns about their election Mark
fincham had the courage to hold the
hearing that led to the Arizona audit
I'm Tudor Dixon and I'm not a politician
I'm pro-god pro-life pro-gun the mega
movement isn't about a person it's not
about a party it's about protecting and
defending our Republic the United States
of America we really are staring down a
perilous outcome in 2022 if even a few
of these officials are swept up into
Power you have made it possible over 200
candidates in the running for U.S Senate
U.S house and top state Executive
offices in the midterms have been given
the nod by Trump of the six House
Republicans running for re-election who
voted to impeach Trump for his role in
the January 6 Capital riots four lost
their primary to a trump loyalist
even people who were emerging in the
wake of January 6 as new
open critics of the president very
quickly fell back into line out of out
of fear I think of Donald Trump
thank you
as the midterm elections approach what
impact will such political machinations
have on the 2024 presidential election
Donald Trump has so changed American
politics he's so poisoned the trust that
a lot of Americans have had in the in
the system that it's going to take a
long time I think for the body politic
to recover from that effect I think at
the national level we could see Congress
people refuse to certify
a vote just last time around scores of
of Republicans refused to certify the
election because Donald Trump lost and
you could see the the system simply
break down
prior to January 6th I would have been
skeptical of political violence uh with
an election but Post January 6th and
with the rise of militia groups that
attacked these transfers of power
political violence is now very much a
concern yes I believe American democracy
is under threat to some extent I've
always feel that way I think it's more
under threat than it's been and I think
it's a good thing for Americans to feel
that way because what's hopeful about it
is it might create a basis for us to
actually do something about it to find
all our coverage of the 2022 midterm
elections click the link thank you very
much for watching and please don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
foreign